here's m going get first penalty over out of the
box Mavis tipped to him shorthanded score Bing
Mavish a short-handed goal with 12 seconds left
and the Ducks lead 43 unbelievable unbelievable
and McTavish just picks that corner over the glove
unbelievable play up a lot of goals as well as Sha
dery will bring it in now dery to the Bry Stars
Shan Jersy oh the magic mullet Arena 41 [Music]
coyotes what a goal will he go for the hidden
[Applause] shot a with the puck on his hip and
scores torture chamber he's going to slow it
down right between the hash marks this might
be his best move he certainly likes it the P
get the goer to fight a little bit just enough
to get down into that butterfly inside the
zone now Benson for Victor olon M Michel took
that pass away Savers get it back again here's
Benson in front what a move scores Zach Benson
with his first NHL goal and that is a beauty
to remember for all time and he pulls his back
between his legs and he's going to put it right
up top underneath the bar right here he's got
everything he could have gone to his back hand
could have done a lot of different things there
pulls this one out no way keer expecting this
get it to the line and outwards picked up by
cadry cadri in with a power move to the slob and
the scores cadri great move off the boards whips
it home makes it one nothing Calgary that is so
hard to do spinning and then just elevates over
the right pad into the K zone drop for Everly
Everly tried to get it back but Brady Shay with
a stellar defensive play now Shay he's got his
motor going Shay to the backand across NES Dr
the back they score yes Barry Co Ki ties it at
two Brady Shay desperately makes the play kicks
it gorthy wizard of all style from his left skate
up to his tape men where you have numbers heck of
a pass and Nate just makes an even better pass to
kenami on his offside left minute of play in the
first period badar takes the puck scores what a
goal by Conor Bard whoa how did he do that where's
holy jumping when you need him what a steal far
down line also on the ice for Avalanche kale back
in M darting him with the back hand Johnny scores
kale Mard he again works it around the defenseman
this time a backhand top shelf shot for his
third of the season and the ABS have taken a
2-1 lead and that was an absolute thing of beauty
just when you think you haven't seen a kale marar
highlight yet you haven't loved he comes in and
buries a back hands rosic walking in Jack rosic
scores the game winner in overtime rosic marches
down the ice a much improved Jack rosik wins this
one for the Blue Jackets heads up play by rosik up
with Couer it's pulled back by the stars and they
get to it Johnston has Peli on the load back in
score Joe pelski Stars winning in overtime watch
the b battle on the draw it's couturier and the
eventual goal score and Joe gets away from the
former Cy winner and it's wide open and then it's
just those Gauzy hands in critical locations to
Bret Lin Baron gobear was one of the two red wi
goals right up the middle in on goal for lin he
scores and there was a penalty coming up but
Dylan Lin has scored the goal and the red WI
up by three a power play goal it's cleared to
the left side and Larin was shot right down the
middle he tucked it and went between the pads up
towards Center and McDavid will hand off to Cece
po three by Kane and now McDavid what a spin the
recovery the shot of th Conor McDavid it's not
real oh I'll tell you we've watched him for so
many 20 years the way he works in the off seon
on edge control spinas everything he can do
and sit really be prepared for this but maybe
he is the most he goes down spin pops back up
and somehow that puck was loose I mean that is
absolute nightmare for that puck to be ahead of
him when he gets up to a shoot out fourth overtime
game for the capitals it's the third and here's
a chance for Park up right in and he scores it's
Reinhardt the winner just 15 seconds into overtime
what a play off the boards perfectly executed and
here I thought he was going to go to the back end
cuz Nets off's on the other side ryanh Hart uses
his strong part of his body protects the puck
uses the forehand right there and then he's
able to hoist it Shen will leave it for bich now
they work it out to the Blue Line broken up in a
break short-handed break Kee in de's scar sweet
hands from HRI and Kee a short-handed goal three
nothing La man he has a couple of stick handles
and watch the goal tender look at b b he loses his
balance there he can't keep up with the puck so he
doesn't know where it is he almost Falls forward
while moving backward kicks lead three to nothing
to Eric now for Maroon Eric s works up front and
scores w the play by Eric s it's 53 Minnesota
the big swed right in his office where he does
most of his heavy lifting Dion gets to the way
Anderson on the pck waits to stay outside plays
it for copio if he moov field from the opening
goal in Montreal what a nice move on the rookie
cinski although he doesn't get in across he gets
to the inside of his backand and gets it upstairs
and it finds its way down the back of morz it
and into the net one nothing mreal we're putting
pressure on right now they really feed feed off
it just like the Predators do with smashville
forb Buffs in drags and holds he shoots scor Ry
provided the traffic late but forsberg able to
deal it all the way to the slot to tie it up oh
what a great individual effort there by Philip
forsberg to create that scoring chance credit
O'Reilly here with going to the net here hard
who is barking at the referee as he heads out for
a new stick Jack swooping in sharp angle SC Here
Comes Jack Hughes High stepping backs off moider
below the goal line goalies close your side door
and if you don't the elite players like Jack
Hughes will take advantage of that daylight or
V barel here's barzel quick turn to the boards
barzel opens up doson do cruising back hand
score no adoption at four on four on the helper
from Matt barzel barzel has just been unbelievable
knows when to pass it when not to pass it look
at the f p and then wait wait wait open it up
okay I'll zip it up over on the right hand side it
accidental here's sa shorthanded drives to the net
he's checked by Delan he got a sh up they score
they score Chris quer a shorthanded goal wow what
a night fabulous efforts by zaban Jad to fight off
a check and find krider on the other side for the
short-handed goal here is bson up in for SCA one
one with C Bear SC and shoots hard wide on the to
go s and drops it back and compar to the pass SC
he BS it in TI St incredible hand play Oh What A
go what a finish to a fun game time is dying and
Dy L have dropped his stick he abandons the zone
and Home Run swing walkoff is what it is for Tim
Sula a pass deflect back toward the AN line and
finding it is Tipp moves around for try to in
and go he scores oh and TI dazzles on his way
in beats toall and the Flyers are back up by three
and what a move on patrono he puts it behind him
he's on the off Wing So when he takes it to his
forehand he's got a lot of net to work with boy
what a play period rine zahor Graves one timer
over the head of lukin a rebound is put in and
Denny Marin with some absolute sorcery from the
corner are you kidding [Music] me nobody expected
that when you least expect it the banking from
the bad angle off the helmet on a onetime on the
backand had to sit on a 102 loss here to the
Pittsburgh Penguins Kevin leang the pass and
they score Anthony duclair and the sharks are
on the board just a minute 4 BR in a beautiful
shot really set up by Ty Emerson on the breakout
and what a finish by duclair and now the Kraken
can reorganized with Will borgan little chip a
nice one gour mcan's in for a chance he scores
that's hockey baby what a goal by Jared mccan just
about 8 minutes gone in Period one Seattle off and
running and canner goes to the backand he brings
it back over to his forehand and then he goes
backhand right into the wall wide open net and
avoids the net just a beautiful play I mean he's
fan of that pass and which davage would have had
a wide open net now he's got a breakaway for the
Hat trip B davic in and he scores the Hat trip for
B davic two hat tricks tonight and the hats are
flying in Denver and the third goal of the night
for pav DAV he's gassed here he's digging in deep
just to get ahead of the players and then what
tremendous patience goes forehand here all the
way back to backand in control of his body it's
blocked and controlled by Celli the quick out
and up the ice comes AC Asim up the middle scores
what a goal by Mikey aimont but the combination of
his stick on the back hand yeah he's partially
blocked there by ham and it ends up going top
shell terrific second effort from Mikey asz has it
goes by him walks ready and shoot and a scolling a
scolling block by Riley picked up by neanders in
with tarz William neander on Johansson defending
in comes neander tries them scores William neander
puts an exclamation point and a brilliant week in
stockh home William neander the star of the show
all week long with a spectacular overtime rush so
much going on there in such tight spaces he makes
it look so easy 30 seconds remaining in the double
minor in nio [Applause] Stern deser dumps one
ahead hoping Miller can get there first he does
he scores what a play by Brock besser to angle
that one off the corner boards Miller there puts
it home on the backand and the Canucks up a two
nothing lead Miller's in behind everybody keeps
it on the back hand right up top little backhand
chip Maro is open but the puck never reached his
stick Michael in the dying seconds of the period
now trying to dance his way through and he scores
oh what a goal D eel with 1.3 to go in the period
a little bit of Juggle as he goes across it's a
loose Puck through two guys and gas tries to play
stick on Stick that's not going to work as eel
takes it to the net and it's a power move and then
it's just great hands in tight point blank and the
shot was stopped by farari as soon as he let it go
now Wilson delays finds a trailing oetkin back for
for stro and he gets knocked down and he scores
oh my goodness what a play stro as he's falling
to the ice beat Schmid and it's two nothing
Washington I cannot believe that he's able to
get control of it here after he falls down it's
not quite the oetkin goal in Arizona his rookie
year but man that was some great athleticism
there by Str following up can't do anything
with it pass ahead and on the left side with speed
it's Kyle Conor off the wing Conor right up front
scores what a goal by Kyle Conor and it's
3-1 Jets forehand backhand and the puck
and all the Defenders for Nashville end up
in the back of the net this is a playoff of
speed